it's been declared an environmental
emergency crude oil washing ashore after
a devastating spill along the peruvian
coast near lima
the tsunami caused by the volcanic
eruption near tonga on january 15th
apparently ruptured an underwater
pipeline as a spanish reptile oil tanker
was unloading crude at a refinery
causing the disaster
an investigation is underway
authorities say the challenge to contain
and clean the estimated 6000 barrels
dumped may be impossible to accomplish
but teams of volunteers at the cavero
beach near the main spill area are doing
their best
a few kilometers away at the bay of
ancon another team is recovering only 20
barrels of the spill per day
it's really not much just a grain of
sand the attention on the cleanup
campaign should be more aggressive
concerned university students have
teamed up to save some species
for now we are cleaning and seeing what
we can do with these crabs because we
are not going to be so heartless and
leave them there
environmental authorities say the damage
now extends 3 000 square kilometers
affecting ancon bay's rich biodiversity
from the fisherman's protected islands
to the coastline fauna
we're about four kilometers off the
coast of the bay of ancon and here the
water is completely under a blanket of
oil the ocean current is helping to
spread it even further making it more
difficult to clean
[Music]
to contain its advance environmental
authorities have cordoned off a small
bay area fisherman avelino ramirez says
more than 800 families who need it for
their living now have nothing to sell
everything has stopped unknown as going
out to sea because we know that the fish
is unusable and will be contaminated
it's surprising that repsol has not had
a contingency plan
on thursday president pedro castillo
declared the environmental emergency
describing the oil spill as the most
worrying ecological disaster in recent
times some are blaming repsol but the
company says it had no warning of the
tsunami and is not responsible
while judicial authorities opened an
investigation experts say reversing the
damage is impossible especially with so
much to be done and with so few
volunteers at work on the ground
mariana sanchez